hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich saison mit luca
wir spielen heute dass google translate
spiel das habe ich zuletzt im dezember
gebracht und das funktioniert ganz
einfach jeder überlegt sich einen satz
schickt den fünf mal durch den google
translator das heißt man übersetzt sind
von deutsch auf weißrussisch ist einfach
scheiße mann schicken einfach einmal
komplett um die welt und am ende kommt
in der regel was ganz komisches raus und
der andere muss probieren bewusst
probieren zu erraten was das
ursprüngliche satz gefüge war ja alles
scheiße scheiße
entsprechend zuversichtlich bist mein
akzent aus ganz gesichts bau kompletter
war ja leute das gilt für lustig dass in
anderen sprachen ausgeben zu lassen
also ganz wichtig die sprache in der es
am ende ausgegeben wird muss deutsch
heim sonst versteht man gar nicht okay
also ich mache einfach mal den anfang
habe mir einen satz überlegt den packe
ich jetzt einfach mal auf walisisch
persische und jetzt packe ich den auch
schon wieder deutsch
hier ist der deutsche satz hund essen
essen ein hund ist essen ein
der hund kann gut essen der original
satz war der hund frisst futter und das
habe ich jetzt sagen der hund ist es
oder hundefutter also fast das gleiche
aber man muss eigentlich versuchen den
original wir überlegen uns falls es
knapp wird irgendwann kriegst du den
punkt ich habe jetzt hier einen
deutschen satz den übersetzt jetzt erst
mal auf französisch spanisch und jetzt
nämlich zu guter letzt das finnische und
packen das finish das übersetzt sich
jetzt auf deutsch das heißt ich lebe
jetzt hier drauf der satz ist shit
sendet nichts markt sendet nicht max
dass man ursprünglich ersetzt oder auf
finnische tk maxx nicht halter also es
können sie so ein starkes sendet nicht
aber ich glaube nicht an diesen rendels
hat sie ihre gegenwart stellte max es
endet mit sendet max keine scheiße der
original satz waren max stinkt nicht
nach scheiße mit sendet nicht mag es
natürlich war es
zwar klingt nicht nach scheiße erfolgt
dank kein problem haben wir nie so was
nettes gesagt bekommen so okay jetzt bin
ich dran mit dem nächsten satz habe ich
jetzt ein paar mal hin und her geschickt
und jetzt übersetzt auf deutsch zurück
bist du verheiratet ich würde sagen das
hast du verheiratet ja warum ich hab das
tausende übersetzt ist dass das
wahrscheinlich so einfach ist
wahrscheinlich so einfach dass daran
nichts verändert wird egal in welche
sprache man es wird jetzt ist okay dann
mach du mal weiter ich nehme jetzt auch
ein relativ einfachen satz und setzt
allererstes übersetze ich es als erstes
habe ich auf walisisch übersetzt jetzt
nämlich dass wir diese jetzt sehe ich
dass man diese chance jetzt auch
französisch übersetzt jetzt nämlich das
französische wieder rein übersetzte das
jetzt auf die traditionelle chinesische
und jetzt nehme ich chinesisch und pack
ist zurück auf der hec gedacht deutsch
ja mit option auf deutsch als auch was
die maximale hintergrundfarbe ist die
hintergrundfarbe denk ich mal ist das
richtige wort also das muss drin
vorgekommen sein weil wenn ich dann habe
ich es vergesse die beste
hintergrundfarbe ist ist braun
vielleicht warum solltest du dass da ein
original
max hat eine braune augen die maximale
hintergrundfarbe heute was ist eure
maximal hintergrundfarbe schreibt in die
kommentare
stärkste kraft
ich würde sagen kran schlachter ist der
beste kran kräfte sie war krank war es
das erste kranfahrer beste youtube
youtube wurde einfach farbe kräfte drei
funktionen einfach ist das schon okay
wir uns einfach erraten
höchstwahrscheinlich gewinnst du und wir
machen nur einmal gewiss echteinsatz
hier aber starkem start der ist easy
eigentlich ich habe auf italienisch
übersetzt jetzt habe ich den auf
novartis und jetzt nämlich das
slowakische haus noch mal hier rein
übersetzt diese und jetzt nämlich
portugiesische übersetzt ist wieder
zurück auf deutsch das heißt wir haben
dieses spiel funktioniert sehr gut ist
richtig das ist richtig am anfang hab
ich doch gesagt dass du nach dem krieg
sind es knapp wird irgendwann kriegt zu
den pumpen
damit hat luca geworden häufig hoffen
das video hat für euch gefallen ja das
glaube ich ziemlich lustig last eines
lasters ursachen hat und aber jetzt
krankhafter konnte ja seine worte lasst
1 leider wenig gefallen
okay leute das was machst du wirst du
nicht nur geschafft